the twitter board of directors has
threatened to trigger an economic poison
pill in its jihad to prevent elon musk
from taking over the company and letting
conservatives speak freely in the
digital public square the poison pill
involves flooding the market with
discounted shares of twitter's stock
available to all shareholders other than
elon musk and any of the associates that
he's working with to take over the
company
this is terrible for shareholders
their their stock is just not going to
be worth as much but the board seems to
think that it is worth it to stop musk
from bringing free speech back to
twitter especially since it turns out
that the board now with the departure of
jack dorsey who helped found twitter the
board owns virtually no stock in twitter
themselves so the board is destroying
shareholder value to push its own woke
agenda awoke agenda that happens to be
shared by twitter's largest
institutional investors
i'm talking about blackrock i'm talking
about state street i'm talking about
others which in recent years have
leveraged their tens of trillions of
dollars in assets under management to
pressure companies to adopt woke
policies specifically on esg
environmental social and governance
issues
elon musk still has several options
with the takeover of twitter
he could team up with other investors to
purchase the company even at the higher
price
he could instigate a revolt among
shareholders who could sue the board for
destroying the value of their stock
he could drag this thing out and
pressure a change in the board members
themselves but
even if that doesn't work
elon musk has already scored a major win
he's pulled back the curtain on the
stinking corruption at twitter
until last week
i never even asked myself who owns
twitter
blackrock
saudi arabia never occurred to me
until last week it never occurred to me
that twitter leadership was so i knew
they wanted to censor but i it didn't
occur to me that they were so hell-bent
on censoring conservatives that they
would destroy the value of their own
stock just to keep doing it it never
occurred to me even me even someone with
a pretty dim view of our ruling class
never occurred to me just how hideously
corrupt the whole system is i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from barry and the
beast
who says
while i have full confidence that jen
perlman could give michael's podcast a
perfectly punny name makeover i think we
all have to agree it must be michael
knowles best with honorable mention to
michael knowles at all
wow you are good because first of all no
one likes a nose at all so i think i'm
going gonna go with your first
suggestion but when we first launched
this show now five years ago
michael knowles best was actually a name
that we kicked around that i really
really liked we should have done it it's
a missed opportunity michael knowles
best what a great name for a show good
point good point thank you all the best
ideas come from you guys
now
you you have a lot of valuable assets
your ideas your grit your patriotism
you've got and
money right you want to protect those
assets which is why i'd recommend you
check out birch gold right now text
knowles to 98 98 98 if your retirement
account has been heavy on stocks for a
while i got great news for you you won
that's amazing the value of your ira or
401k has probably ballooned thanks to
the longest bull market run in u.s
history
and after every bull run comes a
recession right now stock valuations are
at historic highs
only seen before the great depression
and the dot-com crash there's the good
news and then there's the bad news in
the face of teetering global stability
stock volatility is way up so maybe it's
time to take some of your chips off the
table secure your winnings and your
future with gold from birch gold right
now birch gold will help you convert
those gains that you have on paper into
a real physical asset and it will be in
a tax sheltered account nice try irs go
get started right now text knowles canon
wles 298 98 98 with thousands of
satisfied customers and an a plus rating
from the better business bureau birch
gold can help you protect your savings
text knolls know les to 98 98 98 to get
a free info kit on gold no obligation to
get this info go do it right now text
knowles kenneth wlas 298 9898 to protect
at least some of your winnings with gold
go check out birch gold today
elon musk has already won i want him to
win more i want the twitter board to be
brought to heal okay i want not just
twitter that's the smallest of the
social media giants i want facebook i
especially want google i want all of
these guys
to be brought back under some semblance
of democratic rule
or
to be brought back into some semblance
of virtuous leadership but what they're
doing now is so corrupt
and i want elon and other people to
bring them down
but i will say he's already won
in many ways by exposing
just how desperate these guys are to
maintain their power to keep
conservatives out of the public square
to control the whole narrative and to
peddle lies and to censor true
information that threatens the ruling
class and to promote false information
misinformation you know the worst thing
in the world that we've heard over the
past five years to peddle that kind of
misinformation when it's to their
benefit
there's a clip going around the internet
right now
it's a clip of mika bush's azinsky and
joe scarborough on msnbc discussing how
it's a grave threat that
someone wants to take over and control
the narrative because the point of
telling people what to think or the the
people who have the right to tell people
what to think are the establishment
liberal media and there's a little bit
of fake news here because mika is not
talking about elon musk even though a
tweet suggesting that she was had gone
viral she's actually talking about
donald trump here take a listen anyway
well and i think that
the dangerous you know edges here are
that he's trying to undermine the media
trying to make up his own facts
and it could be that while unemployment
and uh the economy worsens he could have
undermined the messaging so much that he
can actually
control
uh exactly what people think and that is
the that is our job
oops
that's the part she's not supposed to
say but that's what all of them believe
and now i love it now you've got the
left wing fact checker types the blue
checks saying this clip is fake news
she's not talking about elon musk she's
talking about trump
who cares she's making the same point
the point is
no less valid than when she's talking
about donald trump years ago than if she
were talking about elon musk today
and it's just as scary and it's just as
corrupt
these hacks at the liberal establishment
media are saying we have we have the
right
to tell people what to think
that's always why they were throwing
this misinformation disinformation label
at donald trump
no one pushes more misinformation and
disinformation than msnbc and cnn
and sure republicans sometimes push
their own talking points i think the
conservatives have been much more
accurate much more faithful to the truth
than the people who tell you that men
are not women the men are women rather
on the left than than people who tell
you that donald trump colluded with the
russians and people who push just
completely made up story lines people
that tell you half the country are
neo-nazi white supremacists people who
tell you that that parents are domestic
terrorists i think the conservatives are
a lot more faithful to the truth than
the libsar in this case
but what what the libs are really upset
about is that someone is threatening
their ability to control the entire
message to control all speech which in a
republic is the government is the
political order because we govern
ourselves by persuading one another and
debating and getting information out to
the public
that clip should go viral
that people should know this is exactly
what these people think and elon musk is
going in and saying look we're not going
to stand for that anymore
and the libs are going after him with
everything they've got they're willing
to destroy twitter to prevent this guy
from letting conservatives speak on
twitter
it just shows you everything you need to
know and we're not only talking about a
handful of purple haired activists at
twitter hq
we're talking about big
institutional power
that controls
trillions and trillions of dollars
why are they so focused on this because
this is not just about some fashionable
social movement or the sincerely held
transgenderist views of
the radical left
this is about a liberal ruling class
that is not going to give up its power
and that is going to
make noises about their great respect
for democracy
but really they don't have any respect
for democracy at all and they simply
want to control their power just like
every other corrupt regime in the
history of the world
and and so are they going to win is this
one eccentric billionaire who owns an
electric car company and a rocket
company is he really going to be able to
crack that regime
maybe maybe not i don't know
but at the very least you do have a big
win here he is exposing the rot not just
the crazy kooky kids on college campuses
we're talking about the political
corruption and rot that goes all the way
down to to the most powerful interests
in our political systems in our finance
in our global financial system in our
media institutions not just in the
united states but around the world a rot
that runs real real
deep
corruption
look at what's happening right now in
just one
agency of the government
story came out you probably didn't even
see it ice the immigration
and customs enforcement
ice
blew 17 million
on hotels for illegal aliens
that's that's the headline it's actually
a lot worse than that
we're in the throes of the worst migrant
surge
in american history
it's going to be last year
we took in 2 million illegals 1 million
legals
this year we're going to take in way
more than that
so
last year among the crazy migrant surge
in march of 2021
ice
entered into an 86.9 million dollar
contract
with the non-profit endeavors for a
six-month period
87 million dollars for six months for
what purpose to house illegal aliens
must be nice must be nice to be put up
at a hotel so the money was for
1239 beds and other hotel services in in
texas and arizona
now this was a a sole source contract so
it wasn't really open to bidding ice
just gave the contract to this
non-profit endeavor
why
why did endeavors get this contract and
it wasn't open to negotiation and
bidding in the free market unclear
probably there was some corruption
then
this the
this sole source contract spent
approximately 17 million dollars for
hotel space and services at six hotels
that went almost entirely unused so they
spent 17 you you have the government
gives this contract to this one group
then this one group gives a bunch of
contracts to hotels
that never have to use the space 17
million dollars
why
if it were me i don't want to sound
cynical i would assume it's because
there was some corruption along the way
and it exposes something about the
illegal immigration problem that it's so
basic that we almost overlook it we say
why is there a major illegal immigration
problem why won't either party do
anything about this why why what's going
on if only i get elected to office then
we can we can change this problem no the
reason that ill eagle immigration
continues and gets worse and worse and
worse is because a lot of people in both
parties frankly are making a lot of
money off of it the reason illegal
immigration is allowed to continue and
why our immigration laws are getting
totally flouted is because of corruption
now
when you want to reach millions and
millions of people i would recommend you
check out podium
right now go to podium.com
knowles if you own a business you know
there are not enough hours in a day to
waste playing phone tag the list of
customers that you need to reach does
not get any shorter especially when
business is good which is why local
businesses everywhere turn to podium
podium makes every interaction as easy
as sending a text that simple
so your business gets done faster podium
is not just a better way to communicate
it's a better way to do everything for
your business gathering reviews
collecting payments even marketing to
your customers podium makes it all as
easy as pressing
send you won't just free up more time
you'll grow your business you'll get
more done with podium you'll close deals
with customers before the competition
even has a chance to call them back
join more than 100 000 businesses that
already use podium to streamline their
customer interactions get started for
free at podium.com knowles that's right
for free or you can sign up for a paid
podium account and get a free credit
card reader restriction supply that's
podium.com
knowles
go check out podium today it's really
basic stuff this is not sometimes we
make politics too complicated and we get
lost in the weeds of the abstractions of
the ideology and the this and the that
a lot of politics just comes down to
dollars and cents why is illegal
immigration allowed to continue well
because the libs get more votes because
corporations that are sort of on the
republican side but more on the chamber
of commerce just cut my taxes and let me
get richer side of the gop
they make a lot more money because they
get cheap labor
the government
has a lot of grift in it
and a lot of people are making a lot of
money
it's big politics attracts big money
period that's always true oh we've got a
major crisis down at the border hey
federal government give my organization
some money
and and don't let anyone else bid on it
and then oh hey hotel groups i got a lot
of money from the government here's a
you scratch my back i scratch yours this
is basic stuff
it's unfortunate
but it's basic there's a lot
a lot of corruption here you want to
talk about corruption the lieutenant
governor of new york
he was just arrested
what was he arrested for corruption
and by the way he is not the first major
new york politician to be arrested for
corruption in recent years it seems like
every few months there is a major
new york politician who is exposed for
corruption the last governor of new york
andy cuomo resigned in disgrace because
of corruption because
of his mismanagement then his cover-ups
than his financial corruption taking
millions and millions of dollars for
this book that didn't sell anywhere near
nearly well enough to justify that kind
of in advance
and rucuomo he becomes governor after
who david patterson david patterson also
had a ton of corruption in his past he
he was not able to continue his
political career david patterson took
over for who eliot spitzer super corrupt
governor who got caught paying zillions
of dollars to high-class hookers
elliot
just on and on and on i haven't even
touched the state senate yet albany new
york the the state capital of new york
is one of the most corrupt places in
america probably rivals illinois
and so when we talk about ideology we
focus a lot of our political debates in
this country on just left versus right
democrat versus republican
progressive versus conservative and that
matters obviously we talk a ton about
political philosophy on this show but
all the political philosophy in the
world is not going to give you a good
flourishing virtuous country if you've
got corruption everywhere this is this
is
this is one of the arguments as to why
we've got to get a little bit tougher on
just the kind of ugly dirty vicious
stuff in our culture
a country that is saturated for instance
um this is a good example because it's
actually happening today
a country that is hooked on a ton of
drugs and porn and weird sex stuff
generally and
corruption and laziness and selfishness
and a country that's hooked on all that
is not going to be a good place to live
it's not going to be a leader it's going
to have declining global influence it's
going to have internal rank or it's not
going to be unified it's that basic john
adams stuff the country is built for
moral and religious people the
constitution's not going to work
for any other kind of people
it's really that simple you can have the
greatest most
precise political philosophy in the
world if you're not practicing that
stuff it's not going to matter well it's
true of our elected officials if our
elected officials are all on the take
and they're all crooks then it the
country is just not going to work
because the incentives are not going to
be aligned to allow it to work and when
i use the political order i'm not just
talking about the government i'm talking
about twitter i'm talking about facebook
i'm talking about google because those
are political entities that are
controlling speech in our country
you've got there have been periods in
american history where the politics the
political debate becomes less about
ideology less about philosophy and more
about just anti-corruption clean it up
you got to do it every so often and
we're in a period of real corruption
jd vance he's running in ohio he's been
on this show before
jd vance is not running a traditional
republican campaign for senate
he's not running a
talking points mid-2000s
cut our taxes and have a strong national
defense kind of republican campaign
his campaign it's it's hard to even call
it a republican campaign because he's so
critical of republicans as well as
democrats what he is running is a throw
the bums out anti-corruption campaign
this ruling class got stinking rich off
the back of ordinary working-class
americans
he's running a campaign that comes
naturally out of his book jd vance's is
the guy who wrote hillbilly elegy which
became very very popular at the
beginning of the trump administration
turned into a big movie
and jd vance is running
in a pretty tight primary now
notably against josh mandel and a couple
other people as well so trump
just came out and endorsed jd vance
trump said
like some others jd vance may have said
some not so great things about me in the
past but he gets it now and i've seen
them seen that in spades he's our best
chance for a victory in what could be a
very tough race
i love how trump has to address this at
the beginning he says look jd vance has
said things about me that i don't like
but nevertheless i'm going to endorse
him and it's true
the knock on jd vance is that he's held
lots of different positions over the
years he has seemed
significantly more liberal at other
times he was against donald trump in
2016.
so
does that mean he is a liar
i guess it could does that mean that his
political views have just changed over
time as circumstances have changed
that's true too it depends if you want
to have the really negative view of him
or the more positive views certainly
people's political my political views
have changed over time i suspect yours
have too
the reason this really matters though
is this race in ohio
is going to show you
which way the republican party is moving
and potentially which way the country is
moving ohio is a state that is a little
bit of a bellwether it kind of shows you
which way the winds are blowing
and and in ohio right now this you're
going to actually see a hint of what's
going on in 2024 because you've got
trump endorsing jd vance and you've got
ted cruz endorsing his opponent josh
mandel
josh mandel is running a little bit more
of a traditional republican type
campaign i mean they're both they're
both speaking in populist terms
but
j uh jd vance is running a a much more
eccentric campaign probably than josh
mandel
and so you've got trump
versus cruz
you're you're you are now seeing in
these senate races in these house races
too a shadow campaign playing out yes
it's about 2022 but it's also about
2024. you've got to look at which
politicians are backing which
politicians who are up right now
and it's it's going to show you who's
got more steam rolling into 2024 is it
going to be trump trump is the leading
republican right now in the 2024
republican nomination contest
ted cruz is the leading senate
republican in the 2024 republican
presidential nomination contest
ron desantis is the leading
gubernatorial candidate in the 2024
republican nomination process
and you were seeing them all come out
and endorse different candidates
donald trump right now endorsed dr oz in
pennsylvania
we'll get to that in a little bit or
maybe maybe later on this week you're
going to see some maybe you'll see ron
desantis come out and endorse a
different guy maybe you'll see ted cruz
come out and endorse a different guy
right now those are probably the three
guys to watch which way is the party
going which way is the country going
it's going i suspect this corruption
issue is going to be a big
issue
and on the on the anti-corruption issue
trump is the leader trump was the one
who
ran in he said i'm not a politician
these guys are old all talk do nothing
throw the bums out
now another major issue
is going to be education and this is
where cruz and desantis are really going
to shine ted cruz has been a major
supporter of he's probably been one of
the leading voices in the country for
school choice ron desantis right now is
having a huge moment on education
because he signed the parental rights
and education bill in florida and that's
going to be a big issue too it's amazing
how corrupt our educational and
scientific institutions have become
there was a tweet i saw over the weekend
from one of my least favorite blue
checks on twitter
he's one of my favorite in the sense
that i get a kick out of him but he's
one of my least favorite
in that he's so
he's just so awful i mean the things
that he is proposing for the country are
so awful i think we should bring back
formal ostracism to get this guy out of
our country that's how that's how awful
his ideas are his name is jack turbin
and he's a nasty fellow
but he's got a lot of credentials
and so he really sums up the ruling
class he's got the stupidest ideas he
doesn't know
he doesn't know
s-h-i-t from shinola and yet he's got
all of these kinds of degrees i think he
was a fellow or something like that at
harvard he's now a child psychiatry
fellow at stanford and he's actively
pushing puberty blockers he's actively
explicitly pushing transing the kids he
says quote puberty blockers temporary
reversible
are more benign than going through a
puberty that can't be undone if you
can't see that then you really need to
reflect on your biases and whether you
consider hashtag trans people at all
when you form your opinions so here we
are we're almost at the bottom of the
slippery slope
several decades ago
people said
if you don't stand by traditional values
and traditional sexual morality why
pretty soon you're going to have men
pretending to be women they all were
laughed at and then when that came to
pass and then men were pretending to be
women and we all had to go along with it
i said pretty soon you're going to have
men walking into the girls bathroom in
the girls locker room and women aren't
going to like that and they said oh
you're crazy that's a crazy slippery
slope that's never going to happen and
so once we got there inevitably then we
got to this point where they said pretty
soon it's not just going to be adults
they're going to
they're going to encourage you to trans
little kids and they said oh that's a
crazy slippery slope and now you have
people
with all the kind of credentials and all
the titles that are ruling class values
coming in and saying yes you have to
trans the kids and if you don't trans
the kids you're a horrible bigot you're
a murderer you're responsible for their
depression and anxiety and it is all
based on
completely bunk science and the thorough
corruption of our scientific
institutions sometimes you got to keep
it simple like your bedroom you can keep
it simple with zuma go to thuma.co
knowles and give your bedroom a refresh
we talk about it a lot on this show
every place you're in is going to either
slightly elevate your spirits or lower
your spirits so elevate your spirits by
elevating your room with thuma thuma
practices an intentional less is more
design philosophy for the bedroom clean
lines subtle curves lifestyle enhancing
details thuma proves that simplicity can
be extraordinarily sophisticated
introducing the bed by thuma minimalist
design features japanese joinery helps
elevate your bedroom made for how you
live the bed by thuma is backed with a
lifetime warranty ships right to your
door in three easy to maneuver boxes and
takes about five ish minutes to assemble
with no tools required it's amazing you
can easily build it yourself even i can
build it myself thuma offers other
bedroom essentials too
to elevate bedtime that's the nightstand
the side table the tray they're all
perfect compliments for the bed create
that feeling of checking into your
favorite boutique hotel suite but at
home with the bed by thuma go to thuma
dot co slash knowles use code knowles
kennedy wlas to receive a 25 credit
toward your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping in the continental u.s
t-h-u-m-a dot c-o slash knowles enter
knowles at checkout for a 25 credit
summa dot co slash knowles enter code
knowles go check out thuma today
americans used to turn to sports to get
away from politics now the left has made
that impossible
the left has turned even sports into a
stage for their radical leftist agenda
nba star jonathan isaac is not having it
isaac faced heavy criticism from the
media for his views on social issues and
vaccines over the past few years because
jonathan isaac was generally speaking
right about those things and the ruling
class was almost uniformly wrong about
those things that's why i'm extremely
excited to announce that jonathan has
decided to write a book with us called
why i stand jonathan's book will be
about the rise of his basketball career
his journey into faith and his strength
to stand alone in the face of immense
pressure the book's available for
pre-order now at amazon reserve your
copy today we'll be right back with a
lot more
the lies that the ruling class are
pushing about puberty blockers and
transiting the kids are so hideous i
can't even read it without my blood
pressure going up i'm a pretty cool guy
i'm pretty much cool as a cucumber this
stuff i read this tweet from this guy
jack turbin who is just such a creep
it's just a nasty little creep
it's it's hard to
read what he's trying to do which is
which is effectively to abuse little
kids call let's call it what it is
i know there's a debate over can we use
the term groomer or not rumor i will
leave that for another day there is no
way you can read this this guy wants to
trans little kids and put them on
cross-sex hormones and mutilate their
bodies that is child abuse that's all it
is and this guy jack turbin he's a child
abuser and maybe he doesn't think he is
or maybe he knows he is or i don't know
i don't really care how he views himself
that is what he is doing and he's
pushing lies about this process
it's really dangerous because there are
probably parents out there who are going
to be confused whose kids are going to
be convinced that they're transgender
because of social movements and because
of creeps in the public schools and and
lots of other factors in our society and
they're not going to know what to do and
they're going to want to do what's best
for their kids and they're going to
inadvertently pump their kids full of
poison it's horrible this guy jack
turbin says that puberty blockers are
temporary and reversible it's just not
true
i've got here a report about a study
it's come out in the new atlantis
journal
it's called growing pains problems with
puberty suppression in treating
transgender dysphoria this is
co-authored by very serious scientists
paul h ruse a professor at washington
university school of medicine lawrence s
mayer a scholar in residence at johns
hopkins school of medicine
which let's not forget johns hopkins
pioneered the transgender surgery
and then ended up shutting it down
because it wasn't helping anybody but
this is probably the top medical school
in the country
uh this guy lawrence mayer is also at
arizona state and paul mchugh who was
at johns hopkins he's a distinguished
professor of psychiatry johns hopkins
university of medicine former
psychiatrist-in-chief at johns hopkins
also who pioneered this transgender
surgery these guys are all pointing to a
huge
increase in young people getting these
kind of transgender
experiments
being done on them
and they're saying this is really
dangerous this is really bad first the
paper says that the treatment is not
necessarily
reversible that actually
what the scientists point out is quote
there are virtually no published reports
even case studies of adolescents
withdrawing from puberty suppressing
drugs and then resuming the normal
pubertal development typical for their
sex so while creeps like this guy jack
turbine say oh the pubert just put your
kid on puberty blockers if you know if
your little boy reaches for a barbie
doll look better to just delay puberty
than to have him discover he's
transgender after it's he's gone through
an irreversible puberty and don't worry
the blockers will be uh will be
temporary
or reversible there's no there's no
evidence of that second
these scientists take on the idea that
treatment is harmless
now puberty blockers what they do is
they pump you full of hormones and they
they s they
suppress secondary sex characteristics
from developing
what these guys write is puberty
suppression hormones prevent the
development of secondary sex
characteristics arrest bone growth
decrease bone accretion
prevent full organization and maturation
of the brain and inhibit fertility we're
talking about really really dangerous
stuff there's so many cases of this one
of the main
puberty blocking drugs is lupron
many patients are not exposed to or
they're not told about the full side
effects of these the extreme side
effects that you can have from from
lupon from the puberty blocking just
temporary reversible stuff uh joint
severe joint pain osteoporosis
compromised immune systems severe mental
health issues such as depression and
even suicidal ideation the fda has
received 24 000 reports of adverse
reactions half of which the agency
itself has admitted are quite serious
just to give you an example of some
some cases of this
and you can just google it
adverse side effects from puberty
blockers uh one person suffered not only
constant pain but strange rashes severe
osteoporosis and multiple surgeries
expert witnesses in court cases brought
here have have concluded that plaintiffs
in these cases have suffered extreme
bone density laws and other symptoms as
a result of lupron beginning at age 17
and the the most important finding of
these reviews uh
shows that 62.5 of patients treated with
lupron for and lupron can be used for
completely different conditions
endometriosis other conditions like that
had not regained baseline estrogen
levels by one year after stopping so the
idea that oh don't worry you go off it
you'll go right back to normal that's
just complete bs and then finally the
idea that puberty blockers are
cautionary
is
absurd the argument that creeps like
jack turbin and these other weird creepy
child abusing column groomers if you
want to people are doing is they're
saying look it's better for your kid to
go on the puberty blockers now
than to let puberty set in
because if the puberty sets in then
their their depression their anxiety
their their
suicidal suicidality is going to get
much much worse there's no evidence of
that
actually
in most cases
gender confusion before puberty is going
to just go away after puberty the
author's right gender identity for
children is elastic that is it can
change over time and plastic that is it
can be shaped by forces like parental
approval and social conditions
and unfortunately what they point out is
this transgender
treatment it's not treatment it's child
abuse
will actually harden feelings of gender
dysphoria so not only will it not make
it better it'll actually make it worse
so that those those rates of suicide
anxiety depression they're going to
they're going to stick around in there i
really encourage you
i really encourage you to uh read up on
this sort of thing but
when i when i think about just at a very
human level when i think about people
like jack durbin when i think about
these creeps in with positions of
authority with the white lab coats
sitting there talking to a confused and
desperate parent of a kid who maybe has
some sexual identity issues and saying
what we recommend if you really love
your kid if you really love your kid and
you don't want your kid to die or kill
himself then what you need to do is
mutilate his body and pump him full of
cross-sex hormones
and don't worry it'll be if you want to
reverse it it'll be fine and then and
then these parents do it they fall into
the lies of these predators like jack
durbin and then their kids end up with
massive bone density loss on walkers
with horrible psychiatric conditions
it's sick it's child abuse people like
this guy jack turban and others who are
pushing this these quacks
these psychopaths who are pushing this
should at the very least be imprisoned
for life there should be a law against
this
they should be prosecuted and they
should face the consequences for these
prosecutions i can think
of few things worse than child abuse
abuse of confused vulnerable little kids
the regret that their parents are going
to feel after they've been lured into
this and these
sickos need to be brought into line by
our law no question
about it it's so corrupt it's so corrupt
because we covered this a week or two
ago
the the
even the government is coming in and
saying no parents it's really good you
need to trans your kids it's really
important that's what the science says
and where are they getting that from
they're getting that from organizations
such as the trevor project which are
conducting studies and surveys on the
effectiveness of tran transgendering the
little kids and where's the trevor
project getting their money from the
trevor project is getting their money
from the pharmaceutical companies like
abvay that are producing the drugs to
trans the kids it's so
freaking corrupt and we should not stand
for this someday
you're going to have generations from
now let's say 100 years from now 200
years from now you are going to read
about
you're not going to you're going to be
dead but you're going to have future
generations reading about what we did to
little kids with this insane sexual
psychosis fetish whatever the hell this
transgender thing is we are going to see
future generations read about this and
say what sickos those people were in the
2020s in the 2030s that they would
conduct these kind of medical
experiments on little kids that were so
abusive a lot of it
a lot of it's stemming from confusion a
lot of it's stemming from corruption you
want you see corruption all throughout
the educational institution there was
there was a math assignment in
pennsylvania
this is the assignment i'm reading this
from snopes by the way so don't accuse
me of misinformation or disinformation
here's a here's a math question
this is a math question from an
assignment from a math teacher in a
pennsylvania school
y equals x plus 2
okay that sounds like a math question
3x
plus 3y
equals 12.
okay now i could probably yeah i could
probably solve that that math question
and then here's the third part of the
math question
maya angelou was sexually abused by her
mother's blank at age eight which shaped
her career choices and motivation for
writing
a boyfriend a02 boyfriend b46 brother c
negative 3 negative 1 father
when i saw this
they go there are others
another question x equals y minus 1 y
equals negative 4 x plus 21 and then the
third part trying to support her son is
a single mother she maya angelou worked
as a pimp prostitute and and then it's
this bookie drug dealer nightclub dancer
these are math
questions on a math assignment when i
saw that i said that's fake news there's
no way that's real there's no way that's
just some conservative hoax there's no
no it's real even this liberal site
snopes admits
that this is true
and they basically just defend it in
january 2017 a high school in the
suburbs of philadelphia
became the subject of international
headlines after a math teacher gave
students a homework assignment that made
references to sexual assault and
prostitution but they say no it's okay
because it was just as part of this
series of assignments to uh celebrate
the maya angelou who's this extremely
leftist writer a absolutely terrible
poet i know it's not it's not
politically correct everyone we've all
got to talk about how great maya angelou
is she's now taught in a lot of schools
she's a horrible poet she's it's do
every second you spend reading maya
angelou's crappy poetry would be is it
just wasted you would be much better
spent reading a good poet
read some keats i don't read
read
i don't know
coleridge shakespeare dante
don't read maya engine it's such a waste
of time and but they defend it and they
all blend it together
and so that even in math class
you have to focus on
the
weird life of a radical leftist poet
why do they do that
they do that because
kids minds are plastic and elastic just
like those authors said in in the
transgender study
and kids minds are plastic and elastic
and they want to shape them and they
want everything to be about leftist
politics not just in
civics class
not just in history class not even just
in literature class they're doing it in
math class too
that's not some innocent
though perhaps misguided
educational theory that is supposed to
improve no that's a political agenda
being taught in math class this is why
it's so funny when the libs in florida
say
there is no transgenderism being taught
in kindergartens or when the libs say
there is no critical race theory being
taught in schools of course of course
there is
there is no critical race theory class
no you're right there's no critical race
theory class critical race theory is in
every class
there is no transgenderism class no
you're right well there sort of is
because there's
sex educate comprehensive sex education
in schools which is teaching a very
leftist view of human sexuality but
beyond that it's being taught in every
class
when there's a math problem
johnny johnny wants to become jane and
he's going 60 miles an hour leaving st
louis you know i'm using a kind of silly
example but when you read these these
actual math problems from pennsylvania
seems a lot less
silly
and the schools are a source of
corruption because it's where the
government can really exercise and
expand its power this is why right now
amid the worst inflation in 40 years at
least
jen saki white house spokesman just in a
podcast with those those lib guys on the
on the pod save america show
is now calling for
the cancellation of student debt
is the president taking executive action
to cancel
some a level of student debt still on
the table and like when is that gonna
yes still on the table still on the
table
so
just to play out what ron claim was
talking about so as you said it ends
august 31st we have to then decide
whether it's extended and what you look
at is uh even though the economy is very
strong we created more jobs last year
than any any year in history um
even though that's the case we know as
we've been talking about costs are too
high
and certainly not having to pay back
student loans nobody's had to pay a
dollar a cent anything in student loans
since the joe biden's been president
and if if that can help people
ease the burden of costs and other parts
of their life that's an important thing
to consider that's a big part of the
consideration so between now and august
31st it's either going to be extended or
we're going to make a decision as ron
referenced about canceling student debt
so economically this makes no sense
but the biden record on the economy
makes no sense either her claim
we in the biden administration created
more jobs than ever last year that's
just a lie
what you did was you let people go back
to work
you didn't create you didn't create any
jobs
you
previous and actually at the end of the
previous administration the government
said you can't work you can't go to work
we're going to shut down huge segments
of the economy
and we're going to just force you to
stay at home
and then biden comes in and slowly he
says okay some of you can go back to
work that's not creating jobs that's
just lifting an extremely burdensome
regulation that allows people to go back
to the things that already existed long
before joe biden got into office but the
the explanation of the student debt
policy
is not economic at all it's not that
it'll fight inflation it's that it is
corrupt it's that it's a payoff it's
that it's going to give the democrats
some at least temporary political
advantage
when you are in a period of high
inflation
it does not make sense
to
just start forgiving huge amounts of
debt
it doesn't make sense for a whole host
of reasons but one of the reasons is
then you're just flooding the economy
with more money but you you don't want
to flood the economy with more money
that's not going to help the inflation
that's going to make inflation much
worse actually
even even larry summers who is obama's
chief economist said that these sorts of
schemes
that the biden administration is cooking
up don't make economic policy sense so
then how do we explain it
furthermore it doesn't make a whole lot
of sense because
something like a quarter of americans
graduate from college
and it tends to be the people who
graduate from college generally make
more money and generally have higher
social outcomes
not always because the value of a
college education is very much in
question these days
but so now you've got a situation where
you've got
the entire american tax base
paying
to
send statistically
rich kids to college
why would you do that that seems like a
very regressive tax from the so-called
progressive administration
well it's a payoff because college
graduates are more likely to support
democrats
so if you
pay off their debts they're going to
like you even more they're going to be
even more likely to support democrats so
it's a payoff to the base but two it's
going to create incentives for kids to
go to college where they're going to
learn all sorts of insane
underwater basket weaving and lesbian
dance theory and just broadly they're
going to learn the leftist view of the
world and they're going to be
indoctrinated there
and so then just again just
statistically they're going to be more
likely to vote for democrats so it
creates an incentive to get more
democrat voters
why not pay off the why not forgive
business loans wouldn't that be a better
way to help the economy i don't think
that's a good idea either by the way but
if you're if you're trying to rev up the
economy why are you forgiving the loans
of sociology majors at
at brandeis or at hamilton when you
could be forgiving certain business
loans where businesses actually incurred
really difficult costs
especially during
covet 19 in the lockdowns
because that's not going to be quite as
politically effective maybe they'll do a
little bit of that too but it's not
going to be as politically effective for
the democrats it's just
corrupt
and on this show i i've i've never
listened to an episode of the
the
pod save america show it's all these old
obama bros that they're kind of a
contrived thing and they were really
being peddled very hard by hollywood for
a while there's a big billboard of them
right on the sunset boulevard and but
despite their best efforts it hasn't
ever really become the broad
cultural
megaphone that i think the libs want it
to be it's just it's kind of like the
daily show
back when the daily show was being run
by jon stewart it doesn't have a huge
it's not the hugest audience but it is
listened to by all the right influential
liberal people and so on this show
jen saki remains on they're having a
casual conversation and she ends up
calling peter ducey at fox news a stupid
sob
because we have to talk about peter
ducey for one second sure
okay okay
[Applause]
is he
a stupid son of a [ __ ]
or
does he play a stupid cinematic on tv
[Applause]
okay um
well
um
he works for a network
okay that um provides people with
questions
that nothing personal to any individual
including people peter ducey but might
make anyone sound like a stupid son of a
[ __ ]
can i tell can i i don't know if this is
not going to be popular in this crowd
but can i tell a nice peter ducey story
come on
people are attacking jen saki for this i
actually really have no problem with jen
saki's answer i find the question from
the pod save america guys to be like
nails on a chalkboard it's just so
soy i guess is how you it's so oh jen
jen what do you think he sounds like a
stupid s.o.b rare
gosh these people are just awful
it just and i actually thought jensaki
answered it well she gives her answer oh
what a good answer rare
but jen's answer was fine they're really
quoting joe biden joe biden referred to
to peter ducey this way and she says
well it's not peter ducey's fault
but i hate i i don't like fox news and
fox news would make anyone sound like
this
and so okay now they're saying this is
uh disrespectful from the press
secretary well look the press secretary
is the spokesman for the president if
the president's gonna say it blame the
president i i don't blame jensaki for
this i don't blame the staff member i do
blame joe biden who is just as tough on
the press as donald trump don't forget
donald trump would go to these rallies
and he'd point back at the cnn booths
and the msnbc boots and he'd say look
back there look at that slime look at
those scum that dirt back there and i
thought that's great that's true first
of all it's true i had no problem i
don't think it's a horrible assault on
journalism and the intrepid
independent reporters no i think it the
the establishment media
are shills and propagandists for the
ruling class it is very good to point
that out it's very good to insult them
as an institution uh that's not quite as
true of conservatives because
conservatives have relatively very very
few outlets very little place in the
establishment media
i
i don't take issue with jensaki i take
issue though with the the liberal
journals who defend her
brian stelter comes out
and brian stelter said absolute go after
that peter ducey
the point she's trying to say there is
that fox pushes story lines that are
sometimes nonsense ducey does that in
the briefing room but still she did it
in a way play into a liberal audience
that certainly is going to cause a lot
of outrage from fox probably for the
next few days right here's what the
network says in a statement uh fox
telling me quote in his role as white
house correspondent peter ducey's job is
to elicit truth from power for the
american public his questions they say
are his own he's a terrific reporter and
we're extremely proud of his work so
basically fox is saying hey we don't
provide him questions he comes up with
it himself so they're defending his
honor
i think jen saki is kind of like
remember in senior year spring of your
senior year you're about to graduate and
you're just tired of all this i think
we're seeing that from jen saki she's
about to leave the white house she's
going to go to a job likely at msnbc so
she's kind of relaxing and maybe to
sharing how she really feels say so it's
the same answer that you heard from the
pod save america guys they're saying ooh
go get him you drag him yes queen slay
but this is very silly coming from brian
stelter one i hate to even say it if the
show were on the other foot don't you
imagine if the rules were reversed but
of course whenever donald trump attacked
the media you would hear this is he's
putting
journalists in danger jim acosta brian
stelter this is an attack on our
democracy and then gensake and joe biden
use language that's at least as
aggressive as donald trump and it's all
funny and it's all caddy and it's
whatever and then they go after fox news
for pushing fake stories
i have no desire or responsibility to
defend fox news fox can defend itself
but it is pretty silly to have cnn
accusing anyone else of pushing fake
stories cnn which pushed the russia hoax
which pushed then i guess the ukraine
hoax the the second reason they
impeached donald trump some years ago
then they pushed
this hoax then they pushed that hoax
then they they pushed so much so many
lies for so many years at a time
that
it
it's not an accident it's not that they
just got a story wrong it speaks to
deep
rank corruption within the system
that system includes the media that
system includes the government and that
system includes the administrative
agencies and that system includes the
nonprofits and the system includes the
corporations and that system includes
big tech and that system includes
twitter and it's why elon musk is doing
us such a public service by exposing it
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 22. if you prefer facts
over feelings aren't offended by the
brutal truth and you can still laugh at
the insanity filling our national news
cycle well tune in to the ben shapiro
show we'll get a whole lot of that and
much more see you there